so a lot of the sessions um have focused  on you know the bigger challenges for  the economies of latin america and all  of them conclude that really it's about  human capital and what you know that in  the end  when you look at economic growth it's  really adding up individual people's  work and then it becomes companies and  then it becomes you know countries over  time so it's what people can  do and actually are able to do that  really makes a difference for how they  progress individually but also how  societies grow so making sure they have  the skills to succeed that they can  innovate that the labor markets allow  for the actual incentives to be in place  for remunerating differently those who  perform better  those who innovate that they have access  to their markets  to place the products in an easy way  those are still the big challenges for  the region and where it should be  heading